five he's like i can't do safe combo two
times in a row etiquette you gotta
please the people
i get it man it's
he's looking to close it out like you
said
dbk though kids strike it any time
miguel deals damage in chunks dude yeah
miguel is definitely one of the harder
hidden attacking characters right now
but watch the rage
unblockable yes four
he's getting scared he's getting scared
i can feel it man
dax has this man
he's got that killer look in his eyes
man
here we go electric main hook face
no way
dude
three
yeah his game plan oh wait a minute
though just as i said frost sends him
downstairs here we go gets the screw all
the way to the other wall nice job
again man he plays this right now
oh yes
two
cursing him oh oh
i mean he did have a great pickup just
there after after weird four that
floated oh big counter hit here already
big knees
tall yes
he gets it straight away that's the
confidence that's what we like to see
taunt jet upper
i hate when that happens man
it's the worst okay walls to his back
now
there it is taunts back forward jet
hopper ladies and gentlemen we've got a
brian player william who's
before you attack brian it's like a look
both ways for you crosstalk you're like
let me make sure i'm really good
man that's two out of three he's hated
i didn't expect one we got two already
oh but wait a minute so frosted coming
back here a lot of damage on the board
already a little raised drive
oh oh it's not over it's not over sam
dude
hold your breath hold your breath
oh my god yeah yeah what the side step
you're gonna see a micro side step right
there
[Music]
[Music]
you